[Musik]
hast du gerade so viel gebracht
ich mach das doch was und aber die
allerdings kanal dreieinhalbtausend
rheinhalle jeder den daumen nach oben
gibt so bei jedem videos abonniert hat
der bald die alle besucher danke danke
und herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
anbau xing video können wir schon sagen
also ich bin auf jeden fall heute sehr
gespannt ich freue mich auf jeden fall
schon sehr drauf ich weiß auch dass ich
schon das ein oder andere mal so eine
drohne getestet haben wir hatten schon
so willig drohen von misch- und so
weiter ich habe jetzt letztes mal wieder
so ein bisschen recherchiert weil ich
natürlich auch immer weitere produkte
suche die ich in meinen videos testen
kann die irgendwie einzigartig sind oder
irgendwas kuh deshalb haben irgendwas wo
man sagen kann ok das könnte vielleicht
ein interessantes video werden und ich
bin unter anderem auch so eine mini
krone gestoßen und ich habe noch nie
eine kleinere drohne gesehen ich wusste
auch gar nicht dass es so kleine drohnen
gibt die sind natürlich auf der einen
seite scheiße weil sie so klein sind und
können halt nicht jetzt so draußen
irgendwie ein bisschen windig ist ich
habe mir zum beispiel auch so eine magic
pro wenn ich mal irgendwie eigentlich
nicht reise oder so dass man mal von
oben bis in die landschaft film kann das
auf jeden fall nice das geht natürlich
wahrscheinlich mit so einer kleinen
bruder nicht ich würde sagen wir selbst
uns war hinter zeige ich euch die
meisten noch echt gespannt ich habe
schon mal ein cookie drohnen habe ich
aber noch nicht gesehen und ich glaube
das ist wirklich als produkt gedacht was
man auch drin benutzen kann also man
muss damit ja nicht zwingend draußen
fliegen oder spiel zurück spielt und ich
habe jetzt ebenfalls kinder immer als
kind und so ein kleines flug ging haben
was ich mir schon gewünscht
und jetzt ist es angekommen hier die man
schon wieder schön und dann wo es
herkommt stellten sie die schönsten
geschichten hinaus standen haben wir
darauf gewartet
also das ist jetzt auf jeden fall hier
die verpackung von der mini drohne sieht
auch schon ziemlich klein aus wenn ich
jetzt
eine andere drohne da denke das ist
schon ein bisschen schwierig die so im
rucksack zu packen die hier kann es
natürlich easy reinhauen
wenn du dir jetzt dann auch noch ne
geile kamera und sollte das wäre
natürlich nein das coole an der
verpackung ist die hat sogar eigene
haare
hier die beschreibung macht auf jeden
fall wieder einen sehr komplizierten
eindruck hälfte auf chinesisch andere
hälfte alles hier mit so grafiken ist
aber was willst du weiter drohenden groß
erklären hier
ich glaube ich muss mal direkt raus ich
habe mich ein bisschen mit drohnen aus
deswegen glaube ich dass ich direkt
heißt nicht explodieren bomben
ja das haben wir auch noch nie passiert
echt ausgedrückt indem du einfach
irgendwelche knöpfe gedrückt werde hier
auch anderen ausgedrückt
hier sieht man schon irgendwie das hier
wir haben auf jeden fall eine leichte
macke vielleicht ist das den hersteller
einmal hierhin gefallen
er weist aber sonst macht das eigentlich
einen guten eindruck ich weiß nicht was
land was hat das gekostet ich gucke das
gleich auf jeden fall mal kurz nach das
dringend leute ich konnte mir zum
beispiel auch schon öfter mal was
umsonst aussuchen jetzt auch bairisch
und so damals länger schon nicht mehr
die besten produkte habe ich alle selber
gekauft das ihr zum beispiel habe ich
auch zugeschickt bekommen muss ich sagen
deswegen wurde durch mittel nicht drüber
ich hatte das schon öfter mal jetzt ein
unboxing videos dass ich oben werden
geschrieben hat einfach weil ich das
produkt kostenlos erhalten habe und da
möchte ich gar keinen stress oder so
haben dass ich es halt an sich als wäre
video kennzeichen muss auch wenn ich
eigentlich kein geld erhalte ich kann
auf meine ganz eigene meinung dazu sagen
also wenn das jetzt irgendwie gleich
scheiße ist dann werdet ihr das aussehen
das produkt verlinkt ich euch wie immer
jetzt in der beschreibung das mache ich
jetzt bei 1 sachen die ich taste weil
ich sehr oft nachrichten bekommen wo ich
dass herr hat genau das sollte jetzt auf
jeden fall noch mal sagen jetzt fangen
wir aber auch mal an hier
ich wollte mal daraus also haben wir
jetzt die drohne guck mal hinten kannst
du rein gucken da ist dann so eine
kleine batterie drin und an sich diese
technik die gern hier drin ist die
reicht aus damit das ding fliegt immer
alles steuern kann
das finde ich schon kalt und es ist ja
so mini me also wer das jetzt so groß
okay ich finde mal so verwundert darüber
wie weit die technik einfach schon ist
gut wir müssen doch erstmal checken dass
es wirklich funktioniert
der flügel ist ein bisschen verboten
ich musste mir ganz kurz einmal auf das
produkt anschauen ich bin doch irgendwie
ich glaube da fehlt nämlich noch was 29
99 partie ist so ok oder besonnen
kleines ding
wir pressen das erste mal vielleicht bin
ich mir überzeugt ich bin echt noch
skeptisch weil ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass das so lies fliegt jetzt
noch eine klappe bei dann kann man das
zu machen oder die aliens kommen hier
raus keine ahnung wir hatten dann noch
irgendwo hier so aha okay doch die haben
wir jetzt noch anscheinend ersatzflüge
und das weiß ich auch was es ist damit
wenn die gleich wahrscheinlich direkt
direkt abgewickelt und gegen die wand
setzt die flügel halt geschützt werden
ich weiß jetzt nicht wie man von ok
wollen wir die eigentlich auch draußen
einmal fliegen lassen
es ist schon dunkel draußen ist das
problem aber kann man ja trotzdem machen
oder einmal bei uns hier erwähnen wurf
ich möchte jetzt mal an ist natürlich
ganz logisch man muss an der drohne
hier soll und auf knopf denn es würde
ich auch mal kurz rüber komme jetzt kann
man hier sehen leuchtet vorne auch noch
ein licht das heißt im dunklen leicht
steigen absolut kein problem
soll ich jetzt einfach mal drücken ich
hab ja echt immer angst vor gut ist
jetzt sehr klein aber
[Musik]
ich werde auf den laptop geklaut
sorry ich hab dir gar nicht mehr gesehen
dies gehe um gegen die decke und dann
genauso ein bildschirm laut polizei
liegen jetzt schon ordentlich ab
manchmal kurz wo ist jetzt natürlich
meinem laptop denn gut naja ich bin
stolz auf versichert guck mal dieser
schutz hier ist abgeflogen okay leute
der schutz ist wieder aufgetaucht
ich habe angst vor diesen dingen ja ich
auch aber kein problem ich habe es nie
unter kontrolle
ich muss jetzt mal ein bisschen weiter
weg gehen damit nicht erkannt hatte
kannst du einfach nur mal hoch fliegen
was ist da oder ich würde gern gesehen
der eine geht nicht mehr
ja ich will einfach nach oben fliegen
nach oben sind nach vorne nein heute
werden es in einer beschreibung gelesen
weil wir sind gerade jetzt ein bisschen
herum experimentieren weil wir so mit
der mit der aerodynamik in der luft ein
paar probleme glaube ich hatte irgendwie
ich weiß nicht vielleicht ist müssen wir
noch kurz laden sowie die laden kurz
leute es ist zwar kein aufwendiges video
aber für uns beide war es ganz so
aufwendig sagt eine studie sicher ich
habe es nicht hingekriegt dass der
fehler war
passt auf ich zeig dir hier waren ja von
anfang an die rotoren drauf und einer
von denen war falsch man erwartet ja
eigentlich dass da die richtigen drauf
sind nur ich habe jetzt genau beobachtet
und der eine hat hält immer runter
gezogen und jetzt habe ich durchprobiert
und irgendwie funktioniert jetzt will
ich schon oft hat er aufgegeben jetzt
echt eine stunde lang habe ich mir dann
lasst uns jetzt mal rausgehen weil jetzt
bin ich mal gespannt wer erstmal hier
zeigen was ich versuche zu geben genau
[Musik]
dann sind es niemals zulassen auf den
film
[Musik]
looping gemacht ich mache das aber
weiter unten wird
helfer
[Musik]
der drogenexperte weißt du was ich schon
gedacht habe aber ich habe nämlich extra
schon hier diese schutz.de gab gemacht
weil ich dachte es liegt daran
irgendwann kommen wir gehen jetzt zwar
noch ausflüge abruft oder länger jetzt
habe ich plötzlich so nuß mehr weil die
vor allem loopings kann ich hab das eben
gelesen ich dachte es fake dann hab ich
hier drauf gedrückt und hat sich hat
sich einfach nur automatisch ja du
kannst hier drücken und dann kannst du
die richtung bestimmen
also das war jetzt schon ein paar meter
oder weil ich hatte nämlich schon mal
eine von bush und die ist nur so 30
meter hoch geflogen das war aber so
einen klotz ok warte bis zum thema das
der luttinger fasziniert mich ein
looping noch eine lupe
[Musik]
das war aus versehen keinen logischen
technischer defekt was soll ich dazu
sagen also erstmal hat meinen letzten
nerv geraubt dann habe ich aber noch
irgendwann hinbekommen ich weiß nicht
ich glaube ich glaube das war irgendwie
jetzt ein fehler dass die den fall schon
flügel drauf gesteckt haben weil in der
beschreibung steht dann nichts dazu
trotzdem war es an sich ein cooles
gadget ist jetzt zwar nicht die beste
qualität aber es hat auf jeden fall spaß
macht oder das kann spaß machen weil mit
den looping zu sein so ein bisschen in
deinem zimmer morgens beim aufstehen
bisschen drohnen fliegen
naja ich hoffe natürlich dass wir
dadurch gefallen lassen dicken daumen
nach oben da abonniert auf jeden fall
den kanal bald eine million habe jetzt
schon wirklich sehr oft gesagt haben es
immer noch nicht geschafft aber wir
nähern uns mit großen schritten
ihr könnt ihr natürlich weitere
vorschläge in diese richtung für
irgendwelche produkt stecken einfach
instagram alexy das produkt ist
natürlich in der video beschreibung
verlinkt und das war zum video
[Musik]